[Music]
it is 8 GMT 11:00 a.m. in Gaza which has
been under non-stop bombardment by
Israel for a fourth day these are live
pictures of the Skies over the Gaza
Strip people waking up this morning to
scenes of Destruction they are growing
concerns about the humanitarian
situation in the besed Palestinian
territory as Israel has cut off supplies
of food water fuel and electricity and
imposed a total Siege of Gaza more than
700 Palestinians have been killed
including 140 children the spokesman for
the military wing of Hamas has warned it
will begin executing Israeli captives if
Israel bombs residential areas in Gaza
without warning now we're getting some
exclusive pictures coming from hospitals
in Gaza where there's a severe shortage
of supplies at least 300 3,000 rather
700 Palestinians have been injured more
than 200 of them children gaza's Health
Ministry has accused Israel of targeting
its ambulances injuring paramedics and
in addition to the shortage of medical
supplies a food crisis is looming the
United Nations says it's been forced to
close all 14 food distribution centers
affecting half a million
people now three Palestinian journalists
have been killed in Israeli airr on a
residential building in Western Gaza
others are reportedly injured meanwhile
Israel says it's retaking control of the
Gaza border and mobilize its troops in
the area these are pictures of Southern
Israel where you can see a mil military
buildup there in the background so far
the military has called up
300,000
reservice well we've got a team of
correspondents on the ground in
Washington DC West Jerusalem in Gaza of
course as well and that's where we begin
with yumna alad in Gaza City forest Gaza
was in complete darkness overnight yumna
there've been new air strikes this
Tuesday morning just bring us up to
speed with what's been happening in the
latest casualties
there FY let me start with the latest uh
as you mentioned uh three air strikes
major air strikes on residential homes
now in the northern part part in the
Central and in the southern part of GA
of Gaza Strip uh have happened in about
an hour ago uh the latest was uh the
house that was targeted in Kan Yunis the
southern strip uh local sources say that
uh uh the house was targeted on top of
the people in it uh we have at least
they have rote out at least five people
killed and dozens of injuries of all the
the uh these three uh Targets on
residential homes while the targeting
still continues we can still hear uh on
top of our heads in Gaza City the sound
of war jets Israeli war jets in the
skies uh looming over our heads now um
when it comes to the shortage of
electricity already the past days uh
Gaza has only been uh uh operating with
4 hours of electricity after the Israeli
energy Minister decided to disrupt the
lines feeding Gaza with 120 megawatts of
electricity that the Palestinian
Authority pays Israel for and now isra
now Palestine or Gaza is just operating
with uh 4 hours of electricity from the
soul power plant uh giving only 80 megaw
of maximum maimum electricity the soul
power plant has uh made warnings saying
that at maximum two days it will run
completely out of fuel if no fuel enters
the Strip This is the fourth day of War
on the Gaza Strip with no fuel no uh no
any kind of Aid entering the Gaza
Strip and and we we're hearing some um
on the background there as you talked to
us some what sounds like planes overhead
um
yumna also we've been getting this
morning some very U gruesome and and
very difficult pictures of injured
people and the scene inside gaza's
hospitals the bombing seems to have been
indiscriminate lots of children injured
journalists being targeted as well talk
to us about the situation inside gaza's
hospitals of course as you said already
there's very little electricity water
and food what is the situation inside
gaza's hospitals right
now in gaza's hospitals they are
overwhelmed with people not just uh kill
people the mors are full they've had to
adjust uh uh tents outside in the yards
of the hospital as extension to the
morgs to carry the bodies uh those who
can take their kill and bury them right
away do that because of the lack of
space while all the all the hospital
sections are filled with injuries uh the
hospitals are telling us that any light
or moderate injuries are not even kept
in hospitals they used to ask them to
leave the hospital but now with all the
Intensive targeting and bombardments
across the Gaza Strip normal residents
are going to the hospitals across Gaza
to take shelter in the yards of the
hospital they're not inside the premises
of the hospital itself but outside in
the yards at least to uh to find a safe
uh Refuge uh of the bombardment or the
continuous bombardment that is
especially targeting homes without prior
notice yesterday El
had to uh we had to evacuate from our
Bureau in a tabah neighborhood in a t
sorry building in a remal neighborhood
after we got warnings to evacuate remal
the entire Ral neighborhood we came here
uh to hiji which is just the opposite of
this street from where I'm standing uh
at about uh 2 a.m. in the morning we got
to warning to evacuate hij because it's
going to be bombarded uh everyone
evacuated quickly everyone was here in
the street and and here at the roots
Hotel even residents from around this
area the hotel uh Lobby was packed with
people just there on the floor but then
uh the journalists who died in the
attack yesterday were in a neighboring
building to and that building was the
one that was bombarded without prior not
no and that's why uh these journalists
and other and and and dozens others were
injured in that bombardment nowhere in
Gaza is safe civilian homes are being
bombed hospitals are overwhelmed and
people are trying to find safety
wherever they can yum nowed thank you
for the update uh now Israel's prime
minister Benyamin Netanyahu has said the
air strikes on Gaza have only just
begun I'm confirming that we have
started attacking Hamas what you're
seeing is just the beginning we have
killed many of those Fighters every
place where Hamas is active and working
will be completely destroyed and we will
continue to intensify
operations let's bring in villain marks
in West Jerusalem for us Netanyahu vilim
says this is just a beginning and it's
been talking about stepping up Israel's
response everyone of course is waiting
for this much anticipated ground
offensive but any more information as to
when when and that's likely to happen
and what the Israel response is like
likely to
be in terms of the details of the
response of course the military here in
Israel keeping a lot of those details
Under Wraps as you might imagine they
have acknowledged throughout the last
few days that all options are on the
table senior politicians in the country
calling for the complete destruction of
Hamas quite how that will be
accomplished though not yet clear in
terms of the political un that Mr
Netanyahu in a public address to the
Israelis last night called for that will
be one of his biggest challenges ahead
of any kind of large scale military
operation he wants to try and bring in
some of his high-profile and experienced
political opponents here many of them
though saying they will not join what's
known as an emergency government without
some preconditions being met and that
includes that some of his current
governing allies are excluded from any
kind of cabinet with uh decision-making
PR Powers over this war thank you vill
for the moment vill marks with the
latest there from West Jerusalem let's
now bring in maub director of the golf
study center at Qatar University maob we
heard there from Netanyahu what do you
think his end game is this in this I
think um it's he has no Clear Vision
according you know after listening to
all of his speeches and the statements
especially with the crisis of governance
he is facing um the information we are
getting from inside Israel there is
serious problem of forming a new
government and bringing the opposition
to the government and let's not forget
the whole current situation is being
referred to the problem of governance
inside Israel because of the radical
government formed by Netanyahu because
of the nature of alliances he has he had
made and led to this kind of
confrontational environment so now
everything there is a saying in America
you know everything about domestic
politics so domestic politics of Israel
now is actually coming back to the scene
again saying okay you need to fix your
in house and now he's facing a real
problem because there is a pressure from
the base on him that you need to bring
some military uh expertise to your
government and those are coming from the
oppos the opponent of of of uh Netanyahu
and they have a precondition as you are
as we are watching now and those
precondition is actually to to
disconnect with current alliances and
that basically will increase the
pressure on Netanyahu and maybe maybe he
will give more concessions to award any
piece uh or any kind of negotiation of
mediation let's broaden this out a
little bit um to the region because the
concern has been since this Hamas attack
that other countries in the region could
be drawn into this conflict we've
already seen some reports suggesting
that Iran had a hand in this and in just
the last few minutes we've heard from
Iran supreme leader hame who says Iran
is not involved was not involved in
hamas's attack on Israel how significant
is this denial the statement is very
interesting it's coming from the supreme
leader who always tried to uh as Western
anal analysis they say he's saying the
final words saying this is ending all of
this um uh stories about Iranian
involvement um I think in the last 24
hours there a lot of statement coming
from Washington saying actually we have
no evidence that Iran is involved and
now what Israel has been saying is
saying I think the whole story is
diversion of of what's Happening inside
uh Gaza bringing Iran is to say that
everything linked to Iran and moving
away from the fact that is Gaza under
occupation and Israel has obligation
toward occupied lands I think bringing
Iran is trying to get more support from
International Community especially
United States and the enemy of ir
because they wanted to say that
everything in the region bad is
happening because of personally I think
this is a humilation of the to the
Palestinians Palestinians they don't
need a wakeup call from tahan to tell
them that they are occupied they don't
need someone to tell them that you live
in under suffering situation they don't
need this they live this situation and
they decided maybe to to tackle this in
the way how they decided now someone
agree disagree with them that's
different story but Palestinian
they are behaving based on what they
live in each minute right the Egyptians
now in all this Egypt of course has
relations with Israel they've mediated
in this conflict in the past there's a
lot of talk right now about the Rafa
crossing the crossing between Egypt and
Gaza yeah because Netanyahu has said to
people in Gaza leave but where are they
going to go to when that Rafa Crossing
as we know is controlled by Egypt and
then they've shut down the other border
as well so what is Egypt going to do in
this situation this is a very difficult
Balancing Act I imagine for the
Egyptians are they going to open this
Raff of Crossing or not Egyptian is
becoming involved in this uh actually in
the last uh 48 Hours of two main thing
things one is having reports saying that
Egyptians have actually warned Israelis
that something important is going to
happen which the Israelis have
categorically denied
that and now they say they talk about ra
I'm pretty sure that Egyptian will not
be easy on opening Raa for different
reasons they already have steps to to
demolish all of the places around RAF uh
uh gate and they don't want they have no
interest to open it and secondly they
want to distance themselves from from
what's Happening as much as they can
because of L um domestic uh uh
calculation Iran Egypt going to
elections and they they have different
calculations I think what's happening
now they try to distant themselves
pushing toward a peaceful solution and
they want to help on this but in what
capacity one capacity on the their
communication and linkage to uh with
with the uh Hamas and other uh um uh
organization andaz ma thank you very
much for the moment uh let's get a a
more update now another update on the
situation inside Gaza and speak to
another Gaza resident ra shabar who's a
writer uh and joining us on the phone
from Gaza ra thank you very much as we
come to you we are looking uh at a live
picture of the Skies over Gaza and
plumes of smoke because there have been
three new air strikes this morning can
you tell us first how you coped how
you're coping under the Relentless
Israeli bombardment of
Gaza yes uh ever since the the attack
started and uh especially during the
night uh the Israeli occupation has
intensified their attacks so for example
last night I mean we didn't sleep it
went it was all bombing throughout the
whole night we were bombing mosques
houses without um uh alerting the
residents uh many people died under the
rebel while they were in their own homes
uh I went out this morning to buy some
things and I couldn't recognize the
streets because because of the uh
enormity of the of the of the bombing um
I mean some places have lost their
features I can't I couldn't recognize
them everything is destroyed the
infrastructure is destroyed the
buildings are destroyed uh the families
are displaced the some of them are are
um are being called in the middle
they're not until evacuate if they're
lucky they to evacuate and so they run
in the middle of the night and they have
nowhere to go so um it's not easy for
any parent or any any person living here
to cope with this R um we can only
imagine what you're going through right
now and we have seen the utter
destruction of Gaza with these buildings
level to the ground you you say that you
went out this morning to buy some things
what are you able to get are are there
supplies available still because as We
Know Israel has said no food and no
water will go into Gaza what's left what
is available
today well um you know in these times
like these we buy just the their
Necessities we just buy bread and uh you
know some cheese you know just basic uh
basic Goods we don't we're not buying
snacks of chocolate bars things like
that so I was able to get uh bread milk
uh some things for the kids and and
because we don't even have an Tri to eat
was just eating to stay alive you know
and are you able to find these supplies
are you able to find the
supplies yes but not all of the stores
are open some of them have been
demolished um so I had to walk you know
uh far to find something um so yeah it's
um it's not easy uh if this goes on for
a prol long period of time um I think
we're going to it's going to be a real
crisis for everyone not only electricity
water but also a food crisis and Health
crisis as well ra thank you so much for
taking the time to speak to us ra shabar
araza Gaza resident talking to us there
on the phone about how people are coping
and dealing with the the Relentless
Israeli bombardment a lack of supplies
as she was saying very little left uh
inside Gaza let's get now an update on
the situation in Israel and Rob Reynolds
is joining us from zakim in southern
Israel not far from the Gaza border
we've heard Israel's military says
saying that it's now in in full control
of the Gaza border can you just tell us
about uh what the situation is there
what's the scene
like well the scene here is is uh one of
uh lots of uh of the Israeli Army troops
uh moving back and forth uh lots and
lots of explosions being here heard uh
as Munitions are fired from areas around
here and impacting on God we can hear
the air strikes and the artillery
strikes on Gaza each one contributing to
more destruction of uh that uh small
Enclave uh and uh we are told that
Israel has uh the Israeli Army has
sealed off all of the breaches in the in
the fences that were created by Hamas
Fighters and other Palestinian Fighters
uh on Saturday uh that is what they say
uh however given the enormous
intelligence and Military preparedness
uh failure that allowed those uh forces
to leave Gaza and uh uh kill many many
people and take uh an undetermined
number of hostages uh we must take that
with a grain of salt and wait and see
whether in fact uh the Palestinian
fighters in Gaza have other capabilities
other routes other tunnels or or things
of that nature that would would allow
them to get out and continue to bring
the fight onto Israeli soil otherwise uh
in Israel itself there are um uh things
are are are have have really kind of
shut down as a society uh lots of stores
uh businesses closed uh so many uh
reservists have been called up that that
there's really no in many cases not not
anyone left to work um and ask you about
that if you allow me to Pi yeah about
the reservist Israel mobilizing a huge
number of reservist 300,000 I believe
the number is is that visible where you
are because everyone has been waiting
for this imminent ground offensive into
Gaza what sort of movements are you
seeing along the border
there well we've seen in some areas
large concentrations of Tanks uh we have
seen uh throughout the past several days
the movement of troops in in various
types of vehicles uh to the uh South and
to the to the east uh where the border
with Gaza continues uh we know that uh
the air strikes and the strikes from
gunships on uh the Mediterranean are
continuing um and you know it's it's
it's had this emptying out effect on
Israeli Society where so many hundreds
of thousands of men and women in the
reservice who had jobs who had
occupations Etc they're now they've left
their jobs very abruptly and they've
they've taken on uh put on their
uniforms so this has left Israeli
Society businesses the economy uh with a
huge gap that is is impossible to fill
at this point uh just uh for example um
at the hotel where we're were staying at
the the staff apologized they said we we
we don't have half of the people who
used to be working here they're all in
the Army now uh and so that that's just
one small sign of how uh this
huge um buildup and and call up of
reservice is affecting Israel Rob
Reynolds with the latest there from the
Israel Gaza border thank you
rob now this is uh the situation in in
Gaza and of course uh the war is uh
raising a lot of concern on the global
stage the European Parliament today is
set to debate what it describes as the
situation in the Middle East and it
comes a day after the EU announced that
it was suspending Palestinian aid but
France is not in favor of suspending Aid
that benefits Palestinians more on this
let's go to Natasha Butler in Paris
Natasha is not just FR France but a
number of countries against this idea of
suspending aids to the Palestinians
bring us up to
dat
yeah look and we have to clarify that
because what's happening today is that
EU foreign ministers are meeting it's a
virtual meeting they're going to be
discussing the situation particularly
this question of financial aid to the
Palestinian territories because on
Monday the commissioner in charge of
this uh announced that this Aid would be
suspended in response uh to the attack
on Israel by Hamas however that was a
decision it seems taken almost
unilaterally by that commissioner a
number of member states including Spain
uh and Ireland said that they were very
concerned by that and that is why the EU
then had to backtrack uh on that and say
look uh it's not been suspended for the
time being we're going to discuss that
later in this meeting and see what we
decide but what we do know is uh that a
number of member States including France
including Spain uh Luxembourg and
Ireland are saying that uh humanitarian
aid for the Palestinian territories must
continue uh to go through particularly
at this time when it is so urgently
needed and we understand that the eu's
foreign policy Chief yose Burell has
said that humanitarian Aid would not be
affected if other Aid was frozen right
and so what then can we expect from that
meeting and how United have the
Europeans being in their response to to
the events in uh Gaza
Israel I mean we've heard almost uh
Universal condemnation from a number
number of member states uh across the
European Union of hamas's attack on
Israel there is of course a lot of
concern about the situation now a lot of
concern for the plight uh of the
Palestinian people which is why so many
uh member states say that it is
absolutely essential that humanitarian
Aid continues to get through to
Palestinians uh on the ground we also uh
know that within the European Union
there are divisions on what should
happen next because there are some
member states who are are in favor uh of
suspending uh uh Aid who say that it is
very critical to send a message that
this is wrong there is concern as well
uh that some of this Aid has perhaps
gone into the hands of Hamas now the EU
has always said that its Aid goes to
ngos on the ground it goes to help
refugees it goes to help uh the
Palestinian Authority pay civil servants
wages for example that this money is not
going into the hands of Hamas directly
or indirectly but that will be something
as well that will be discussed at this
meeting but as you can imagine all
member states looking at this very
closely they don't all agree that's
often the case uh in the European Union
there are 27 member states they don't
always have the same point of view but
no doubt they all share the sense of
urgency thank you Natasha for that
Natasha Butler live there in Paris let's
now cross over to John hendren in
Washington DC John Natasha was saying
there are divisions within the European
Union but unconditional us support for
Israel is the only only thing that
Republican and Democrats can agree on
there yeah you're not seeing that kind
of division here the White House is
currently bathed in blue and white light
the colors of the Israeli flag and
that's a powerful statement about where
American sentiment lies this is an
increasingly diverse country where you
have more Arab and Muslim
Americans and you've got uh Pro
Palestinian rallies in the streets but
you're not seeing that response from a
Unified Government where both Democrats
and Republicans have agreed they're
they're actually bickering about who is
more pro-israel and that's why you're
hearing from the Biden Administration
that they're going to send more military
equipment they're sending a US Carrier
Group to the Eastern Mediterranean
they're offering intelligence
surveillance and reconnaissance to the
Israeli military and while a White House
spokesman says they don't foresee any us
boots on the ground there's no talk of
that now they say there is a big us
stake here 11 Americans are now known to
be dead in that conflict more likely
among the captives being held there so
until this conflict is over there's very
little talk Of any diplomatic solution
ultimately in that region very little
talk Of A two-state solution while the
US government unites behind Israel John
thank you for that John henin live there
in Washington DC now as we mentioned
earlier Iran supreme leader has denied
any Iranian involvement in the Hamas
attacks on Israel he also o told an
audience at a military academy that tan
supports and defends Palestine and its
resistance let's bring in our
correspondent in Iran's Capital daa
Jabari daa there's been days of
speculation about Iran's role in Hamas
attack in the Supreme Leader there
denying any involvement how significant
is this denial and what more do he have
to
say well certainly um fully the um
supreme leader Ayatollah Ali is the
commander-in chief of of the country's
entire Armed Forces so his word is
extremely important and significant he
was speaking at a graduation ceremony at
Imam Ali uh Military University here in
the capital where he spent quite a bit
of time um expressing his views and the
position of Iran when it comes to the
events that have unfolded in uh Gaza and
Israel the uh supreme leader said that
the accusations that have been hled that
Iran was behind these attacks are
nonsense and that whoever is making them
doesn't really understand the
Palestinian uh people and that uh it is
really to their own detriment of course
Iran supports Palestine and they will
continue to do so but they are not the
ones that had anything to do with the
attacks that took place the supreme
leader also went on to say that um the
uh that Israel has not only suffered a
failure but he made a point of stressing
that they have now uh suffered
irreparable damage to their
infrastructure something that cannot be
fixed he
also went on to say that they suffered a
blow that uh they are now as a result of
the blow that they've suffered the
Israelis are changing the narrative so
that they are now the victims instead of
the oppressors and that is something
that is very very detrimental to them
and they will suffer the consequences as
a result of that he also said DSA that
Iran supports and defends Palestine and
its
resistance in what way how is Iran
supporting the Palestinians
today well he doesn't specify of course
but from what we know they are willing
to um support them in terms of
humanitarian Aid uh when it comes to
Military Support Iran has denied
providing any assistance to the
Palestinian resistance groups uh but
they have said that they are willing to
do whatever is necessary whatever the
Palestinian uh groups will need from
Iran they are willing to uh provide them
with it but for now uh we understand his
comments to mean of course uh
humanitarian assistance uh for the time
being and uh he said that the
Palestinian cause is certainly important
it should not only be important to Iran
but all uh Muslim nations uh in the
world and they should all come to the
aid of the Palestinian people thank you
for that update from Iran dos Jabari
live there with the latest lines from
Iran where the supreme leader hame has
denied